amongst birds of prey it is a king the
Golden Eagle North America's largest
Raptor this bird is an incredible
hunting machine a 7-foot wingspan
razor-sharp vision its eyes can spot
prey from over 2 miles away and a killer
150 mile per hour dive which means this
Jackrabbit doesn't stand a chance
Jack rabbits are a favorite prey of
Golden Eagles and a hopping pack of
protein the rabbit can run as fast as 40
miles an hour but that's no match for
talons that descend from above the Big
Bird has an incredible grip it can
squeeze over 750 pounds per square inch
so most prey are killed instantly in
addition to jack rabbits the golden
eagle mainly preys on other small
mammals reptiles birds fish and even
large insects they're also known to eat
carrion these Raptors are found all over
the northern hemisphere and can live for
almost 20 years in the wild so if you're
a jackrabbit you might want to keep one
eye and ear on the sky